I told him if I answer his question and
I never the deal was never he had to
reply back. I'll let him reply back. I
don't care. But I'm not going to answer
it. But I told him if I answer his
question, he has to answer one of my
questions. That was the deal.
>> It's
God. [music] It's
God.
>> So we add and remove from We did not add
or remove from
I gave No. Yeah. Yeah. I gave you
explanation. Now you said you said after
giving my explanation you you didn't say
>> brother. All right.
>> What?
>> Brother.
>> How you guys doing?
>> He's another liar from the Christian
side.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> He's a true
Christian side. That's crazy.
>> Now stick to your deal.
>> No. No. No. No. No. Brother
question still.
>> So can we add and remove from the prize?
>> No. But we can give explanation. Wait.
>> We'll answer that as soon as you answer
ours. We answer the question. Now you
answer. answered you to the question. We
answered questions. I'm not repeating.
Are you going to keep Are you going to
keep dodging issues?
>> First of all, you did not answer the
question.
>> We had a whole a whole deal. We gave you
a whole deal.
>> We had a whole deal. I gave you my
answer.
>> We're going to ask Okay.
>> Don't involve guns of him. We had a deal
with him. If we answer his question,
he'll answer one of our questions.
>> All right. You're being a
>> brother.
I'll answer. [laughter]
I will answer. You'll answer. I'm not
trying to come out with you.
>> Earlier when someone else tried to join
the conversation, he didn't let them cuz
he said it was he was talking to us. So,
we're not going to let you join cuz he
saw but no he didn't let he didn't let
our Muslim brother jump in with us.
>> The Muslim brother.
>> He didn't let us jump in with us and
>> so we're talking to you now. We're not
let anyone else.
>> Sorry guys. I'm here. I'm here now
though.
>> Yeah, but our our guy was here too and
he didn't let him jump in. We're
respectful to him.
>> No. Because I was I talked to him and
then he went see two more people and he
just come in there. So I was adding
something. So anyway, the question we're
not not involving anyone else. He didn't
let us involve our brother.
>> I'm just saying what was the topic?
>> No, but he didn't he didn't even let our
brother talk in
>> That's not a brother, man. What you
talking about, brother? We work
together, man.
>> Oh my god. Can we please
>> We won't be This stinks.
>> We We won't be able to move on. Let's
move on, guys. Let's Let's Let's Let's
progress the conversation.
>> I'm not disrespectful. We're talking to
him.
>> We're talking I'm with you guys. No,
brother. Your brother understanding
though our our friend he came and he
wanted to talk to him.
>> See that's Islamic. That's lying.
[clears throat] That's your friend. Why
are you lying that now?
>> All all Muslims are friends. We're
friends. I seen him. We were friends. So
three people were talking to no no. We
were talking to him and our friend came
up and he said he said no. So he said it
was adding he was adding [music]
something and I said you going to jump
from there. So let's go focus one
question. That's the only thing I think
I told him. I said that you can talk to
us but you know don't get off from the
subject. [music] Okay. That's why he
tried to go for it. They have to answer
my question. I said, "No, we're going to
stay on the one topic." All right. The
question is here. You said that angel
spoke to Muhammad. You couldn't even
answer my question. [music]
>> We're going. Are you done? Sorry. Are
you done?
>> Yeah, I'm done for you.
>> I haven't said anything. [laughter]
Don't have anything to say.
>> Yo, don't waste your time with me.
Dispatch,
>> I think I know he's don't like
discussions.
>> Could you just simply admit that you
just told no one else to join the
conversation?
>> [__]
>> Yeah. before when he
>> can you just say that you didn't let him
jump into the conversation.
>> Yeah, but you know what he was saying.
Okay. The reason was he was saying that
he was trying to go for out of the
topic. Okay. Oh, he wasn't.
>> Yes, he was. He was telling me to give
me answer. Give me answer.
>> So So is is it fair that cuz it looked
like he it was him talking to you too
and then he tried to come in add to it,
right? And he said no cuz he was and now
his point is that he was he was uh uh
bringing a different subject. I I I
understand. I understand. So we this is
where we're stuck at. Okay. So I think
it's fair that we stay on the subject of
what you guys are talking about and if
somebody's coming in we're untest
I told him if I answer his question and
I never the deal was never he had to
reply back. I'll let him reply back. I
don't care if I'm not going to answer it
but I told him if I answer his question
he has to answer one of my questions.
That was the deal. And we we said deal.
And we said deal. And I answer his
question. And I was going back and
forth.
>> I'll take I'll take a question. The way
you answer it, I'll answer that. Go
ahead. Go ahead. Question. Go ahead.
>> Question. Sure. Okay. Can you guys
please or you
>> specifically? If not, if he needs help,
that's fine. [laughter]
[laughter]
>> If Jesus spoke Aramaic and the last like
version of the Bible was not in Aramaic,
how like how do you explain that? It was
in Greek. Okay, the translation.
>> Wait, first let him speak. I want first
of all, first of all is uh Jesus was
that has nothing to do with the Bible
because Bible Jesus did not write down
the Bible. People they write down the
Bible.
>> Unknown writer, unknown writer wrote
lies.
>> Who are the people that wrote down
>> like I said Peter, Matthew, John and
they wrote down Jesus was speaking.
Jesus speak other different languages
too. Like you know I'm from Pakistan.
All right. So I speak Hindi, I speak
Udu, I speak Punjabi. All right. But
that doesn't mean that. But I say that I
speak U that's the nation my uh country
uh international language but that has
nothing to do that. So because
you get that
>> come on dude chill man.
>> Let's just let's just concentrate on on
the conversation.
>> Sit down here.
>> No bro he's
our conversation asking somebody.
>> So so so really quick. So really quick
with with this question that you guys
asked. Um would you would you would you
say
>> okay no he's with y'all. He's a hired
hired him.
>> He's a [__] Are you Are YOU GUYS STILL
[laughter]
>> You came You came to me as your friend.
>> All right. So to get him
>> to get back focused to get back focus to
this question. So So are are you saying
like do you have a problem with the with
the Bible not being in Aramaic? No, I
don't have a problem with how it was
translated throughout the years.
>> I'm just asking how it makes sense that
So you guys think Jesus God, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And he's the one you just said he didn't
write it. So who wrote it?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John wrote the Bible, wrote the gospel.
Yeah.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. Like, like for example, like you
you believe you believe Muhammad um
recited the Quran, his companions wrote
down what he preached, right? Same thing
here.
>> Okay. Okay. Would you argue that the
Quran is the most wellpreserved book in
all of history?
>> Absolutely not.
>> Abs. What's what's the most uh what?
>> The Bible.
>> Yeah. There's nothing that comes close.
>> So, how can you explain that there's
different versions of the Bible, but not
different versions of the Quran?
>> Okay. No. No. All right. I I I love
this. I love this topic. How you guys
say there's different versions of the
Quran? Let me
>> Not that. Yep. Okay. So what would you
say is a different version?
>> No, no, no. Look,
>> you guys, this this is your argument
always, right? I know. You guys say
different versions of the Quran. Yeah,
I'm telling you there's different
versions of the Quran, right?
>> There there is different versions of the
Quran now, but they're not they're not
different. There's still one version.
It's called It's It's in
>> the skeleton.
>> Fa No, it's called Fa. It's It's the
original Arabic.
>> No, that's not what he's talking about.
>> No, it's called Fusa. It's the original
Arabic. That's It's like the main
Arabic.
>> Does it have diitical marks?
>> Uh
>> yeah.
He want to show seven dialect the seven
but that one
barge hats those dialects bars
>> like like the
>> cuz that's important because it wasn't
until the diritical marks came in that
people were able to tell what they were
reading and what words they were saying
cuz the words looked exactly the same
you know without the diietritical marks
they don't know how to say it and the
diietritical mark can change the whole
meaning of the word you get what I'm
[__]
>> How do you spell it?
>> F.
>> What is that? What does that word mean?
>> It's just like
>> it's just like the like formal.
>> Yeah. The formal Arabic like just
>> it's like the mainstream like the
standard form.
>> It's just Yeah. The standard standard
formal
>> formal. When you say that this person is
profession
that he's familiar with the language
dramas
language
I don't I word
>> he wants to play game on that
>> play on that on that hadith you're
saying the seven the seven different
dialects of two or
>> if you if you listen to him he's going
to take you somewhere else he doesn't
that we have today in different dialects
so there Syrian Punjabi or Indian or
whatever. No, no, but the original
Quran. That's fat. I got you. So, I'm
not talking about that.
>> The most well preserved book in all of
history, not unlike the Bible.
>> All right. So, which one is that? Which
one is has the fuss Arabic?
>> The dialect of Prophet Muhammad is half
>> fluent to be fluent in language.
>> Yeah. So, that's okay. Oh, so to be
fluent in the Arabic, that's fine and
all. I just want to know which of these
Qurans is the has the standard Arabic
>> Quran. One Quran.
>> I I'm holding two of them. I have
>> Those are just different languages.
>> No, this is Arabic. They're both in
Arabic.
>> This is I told you this is
this is Huffs.
>> That hadith that says Quran was revealed
in seven dialects.
>> No, it's not. This didn't exist in the
in in Muhammad's time. Sorry.
>> All right. Can you show us one
difference in it?
>> Sure.
>> There are differences.
>> Yeah, but all of them are.
>> See, even even the Shia admits it. We're
going to go to chapter two. Uh yeah, you
you can help us, brother.
>> Oh, this is Shia. No, no, no. These are
everybody, whether you're Sunni or Shia,
everybody uses us. Thank you. Um
180 uh Mas.
>> Yeah. Okay, there we go.
>> So this one, this is the Huffs,
>> the Birmingham Quran. That's the
original one.
>> That's only that's not a full original
one.
>> I hear what you're saying. That's not a
full Quran. That's only uh like two
pages fragments of it. But that is the
original Quran that we have dated back
and prophet Muhammad.
>> So where do you get the rest of it from?
Cuz it's only two pages. a few pages of
Sarah Bakar.
>> You get what I'm saying?
>> There's no complete Quran actually.
>> Yeah. So, you don't you don't have a
complete manuscript that goes back to to
Muhammad, let alone that goes back to
Umar who compiled it after Muhammad,
>> the second compilation
>> at the time of Moses. How about that
one?
>> That's not That's not the argument.
>> We can make the same argument.
>> No, you cannot cuz we're not making the
same claim that you're making
>> the same. You have the exact
>> Are we Are we Are we Hold on. Are we
making the claim that the Bible is the
word for word speech of God?
>> So you don't you don't make that claim,
right?
>> I just asked you the question.
>> Okay. You do you make that claim or not?
>> So you don't know, brother. I'm not I'm
going to keep talking to them. My time
>> you say you can't prove that your book
is by God.
>> No, that's not that's not what I said.
That's why I got you.
>> You show me manuscript but the time of
Moses.
>> Okay. Thank you. Time of
>> I don't need to. I All I need is the
time of Muhammad.
>> There's no Sorry. You got Could someone
go to the
>> Yeah. Yeah. Somebody take them off.
Yeah. Like James,
>> brother, I debated him. I debated him
last week.
>> Please ask him to stay away from me.
>> You guys ask him to leave because you
can ask him that doesn't know the issue
when how you
>> you uh you read Arabic. Is that right,
brother?
>> I understand.
>> Brother, do you do you read Arabic too?
>> A little bit. Okay. Well, we got Arabic
speakers here. He reads Arabic. These
two brothers, they read Arabic. So, we
can look at the differences in these
Qurans. We'll show you guys.
you asking for that doesn't matter.
Okay. I'm sorry.
>> Really [clears throat] quick, what are
you looking at real quick?
>> I'm looking at research.
>> Okay. That's all right. That's all
right. We're in this together.
>> So, can I just show you guys a quick
difference that I'm talking about?
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> And Marvin, if you ever want to say
anything, just say something, bro.
>> Are you guys all Christian?
>> Yes, sir. Including he he'll be
Christian soon.
>> What? What?
>> Just Christian? Christian Bible. Yeah,
we're all Christian.
>> Are you a cardiologist?
>> Yeah. Yeah, we're YouTube or what?
>> Yeah. God. Yeah. God logic. Uh, this is
divine dialogue.
>> Don't touch my stuff, man.
>> Can I ask a question?
>> Don't touch my stuff.
>> Are you guys ready to answer a question
right now?
>> No, we kind of want to stick to the
toms.
>> You guys are so petty, man. This is This
is insane.
>> All right, we'll come to
>> We're just waiting for our friend. He's
doing research.
>> Can I show you a quick difference?
>> Wait, I'm trying to
>> Oh, actually, you know what? No.
>> Okay. All right. So, this is Sur Bakar.
>> Okay. Um the highlighted word right
there. Can you hold this one?
>> Yes. So, if you can read that verse,
this is talking about what to do after
you miss a fast day. This one.
>> Yeah. Same same verse.
Yeah. So this one is masak and this one
is
>> right.
>> Mhm.
>> So So now what the difference this with
this one msk right? This is in the
singular a poor person right this one
masakin is poor people right. So what
the verse is saying and this is this is
why this is important.
>> You have English of the same or no
>> we have an English of the h.
>> Yeah. Can you can I see that? See the
whole surah you know.
>> Yeah. Uh, can we get an English? Oh,
yeah. We can use this one.
>> I'm gonna move your camera even.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> Why? Why are you being petty, man?
>> What are you doing? You blocking the
camera and everything, dog.
>> I give you everything. Give you
>> Oh, that doesn't have English in here.
>> Okay.
>> Let's get here a little closer. So,
>> yeah. Come this way.
>> In the shade, bro. In the shade.
>> Come this way. Come this way.
>> We're going to get You can put it right
here.
>> And then uh face it towards us
>> in the shade over here. This way, guys.
>> All right. There we go. All right. So,
>> which one?
>> So, chapter
>> Oh, this one.
>> Yeah. You wanted the English one, right?
English translation. Yeah. So, um
chapter two. Does this one go left or
right?
>> Right to left.
>> We'll be back. Wo. We're going to come
back. I swear we're going to come back.
I promise you'll come back. I swear I'll
come back. [laughter]
[clears throat]
>> They never came back. [laughter]
>> [music]
[music]
>> Why didn't that come back?
Oh, [screaming]